all right I'm going to call the
subcommittee meeting to order
uh everybody in the room uh I'm gonna
call the meeting to order if you'd like
to continue conversations I just ask
that you take them briefly outside
um otherwise if we could get everybody's
attention that would be fantastic
thank you so much everybody it's good to
see you
um
all right so we have four bills to look
at and we are dealing with early bills
um so our time frame is a little bit
constricted I'm going to start with HP
250.
I could
um and just open it up to to people on
the subcommittee as to whether or not
you have questions that you feel like
haven't been answered that you need uh
information on in order to make a good
decision on that particular bill
foreign
yes representative thank you Mr chair
um
I know in the uh
in the revised uh the physical note 125
23.
um
it's stated at the bottom uh it should
be noted the physical impact of this
bill will go well beyond uh 2026.
is is that
a million dollars a year
um
continuing
every year well what would be
the physical impact well beyond 2026. so
I don't know what that that figure would
mean
Marty do you have any information on
that
thank you Mr chair for the record uh
Marty Carlin from nhrs uh in reference
to uh Representatives question there
there's two components to to two two
parts to the to the answer
um any um identified unfunded liability
associated with the bill for prior
benefit accruals that haven't been
funded that that's going to be paid off
over a um
20-year close period beginning in fiscal
26 that's the next raid setting
valuation and FY 23 will set the rates
beginning in 26. so that unfunded
piece associated with that would would
be paid down over 20 years there is and
I don't have a breakdown from the
actuary on that you know there is an
ongoing normal cost component to that
which is
refunding that benefit before it's
accrued so um you know so you know that
it won't be that amount forever the the
you know the one million or the four
million uh the you know some fraction of
that is going to be a permanent addition
to the uh group two rates but uh the
unfunded piece is gonna get it's
basically on a 20-year payoff
yes representative Schmidt thank you Mr
chairman so Marty uh you know we we've
seen uh analogous bills anyway uh uh
over the years that wanted to tap into
the the system uh and one of the reasons
that we were
reluctant to get involved in that
previously was in each case we were
going to be kicking ourselves backwards
in terms of getting out from underneath
the ual right and is this it is
analogous or it is the same situation
we're just better off now
well if if you're you're making uh
benefit changes that would have some
aspect of unfunded it you know it does
add to the cost but you have to weigh
the the policy consideration of of does
this make sense from a you know a a
policy perspective and that that's
something we wouldn't a pine on you know
does you know is this
you know in in the view of this
committee does this um legislation right
a wrong or correct something in the
right in the in the statute that should
be changed but but that's I'm not
getting at that aspect I'm getting at
the aspect of whether we're pushing
ourselves backwards in terms of getting
out from underneath okay in general
terms anytime you're
modifying benefits on the on the
increased side you know there's going to
be an unfunded piece to that unless it's
um future hires and you're adding that
you know we do have the statutory
layered amortization to pay that down so
it's more manageable than it was 10
years ago when it was sort of a blank
check rolling forever you know there's a
there's more of a window to
pay these down now the way the statute
is structured I mean at the time we were
paying basically just interest we
weren't drawing down the uaal we were we
were just paying interest yeah so we're
just adding to our interest costs so
this is a we are in a better situation
okay thank you
Marty um oh one second I'll get right to
you
um this is a situation and I have to
apologize I wasn't here for the public
hearing on this bill
um this is a situation if somebody
reaches retirement age uh their
surviving spouse gets 100 of the benefit
uh this is a
active uh accidental death benefit right
yeah um so comparatively to the uh
working and who who is killed you know
you know in a work related death
um you know while still an active member
the the
um beneficiary or the spouse would get
100 instead of 50 of their their pension
as calculated on the on the day they
passed right but if they reached
retirement age uh and then they passed
their spouse would have access to 100 of
the of the benefit for accidental death
that that is um
any um no no I understand The Accidental
I'm sorry if I'm not being clear I'm
saying they don't die before they retire
they actually reach retirement age they
start getting their pension and then
after that they die does the surviving
spouse receive 100 of the benefit oh
okay I'm sorry representative when
someone retires they can designate a
survivorship option on their retirement
application and leave 50 or 100 or some
other amount to a designated beneficiary
it doesn't have to be a spouse many
people choose that if they're in that
sort of relationship
um in that that this bill wouldn't
change the benefits for any of those
folks those that's a separate
designation as part of the retirement
process this is a pre-retirement uh
death benefit so just so I can be clear
at the point I'm trying to get at
somebody reaches retirement age
starts collecting their benefit passes
away
their spout they can give up to 100 of
the benefit to a Survivor they die in
the line of duty three weeks before they
reach retirement age
they only have access to 50 am I
understanding that correctly I'm just
trying to make sure that my head's
wrapped around this
um yeah basically you know it's if it's
an active death that there are different
statutory Provisions that cover that and
and right now that that active
accidental is what it's referred to in
the statute death benefit is uh 50 of
the pension to the surviving spouse or
if there's no spouse this contingent for
if there's dependent parents or children
um if if they did not have a spouse the
Alum sum would be paid to a beneficiary
of accumulated contributions plus salary
so so it is it's this this would this
bill would change the structure of that
uh active death benefit but not not
anything for anybody who's retired or
anything like that yeah you know they
have they have their own choices to make
on those survivorship options and those
would remain in Force if they passed
away after retirement I think
representative gerhardt
do you have somebody filling out the
sheets
I haven't been for this these bills oh
yeah if we get to it I'll let you know
just a clarification on the question you
just asked so Marty correctly if I'm
wrong but I believe
um you know if they're gonna especially
if they've retired and they want to
specify a uh Survivor benefit whether
it's 100 50 or more whatever they're
actually paying for that because they're
going to get a reduced benefit is that
that's correct yeah so we're not paying
for it our the other retirees they are
okay that makes sense thank you
yes representative Schmidt
initially was a little bit concerned
because I had to miss a couple of bills
as well when I was in another committee
testifying on some of my own legislation
but
um
coming back I am I I'm sure I heard this
bill so what we're talking about though
is not uh an ordinary sort of outcome
it's it's only involves accidental
deaths and we had we've had numerous
bills over the years that have in a
provided death benefits
and as I recall we were looking at the
cost of doing it through insurance and
we determined that the
likelihood of any of these incidents
occurring was sufficiently small that we
were better off paying it out of the
general fund than incurring the cost of
of the insurance that might never be
it's like an accident you never have in
this particular situation there's some
kind of statistical
uh probability calculation that you do
what is the likelihood of an accidental
death based on you know all the other
factors that are involved is that not
the case that's the case that that
analysis of you know buying you know
spot Market insurance for you know death
and disability versus including you know
the plan was conducted before I got here
but what you just said was my
recollection of the record that I read
on it
um I'm not sure you know somewhere in
the 2000s or
thank you
anybody else
have any questions that they really feel
like they need clarification yes
representative true
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I don't know I don't
know if you have the the original
physical note
I I don't have it with me
um the only difference in the fiscal
note though would have been initially
um you know the accurate was projecting
what the cost would be beginning in the
24-25 biennium and we noticed that and
and pointed out well we're not going to
recertify those rates those have already
been presented to the employers into the
state you know so we you know when
they're far along in their budgeting
processes for for the next fiscal year
so we asked them to restart re issue the
notes basically showing the cost
beginning to show up in 2627 but the
analysis it's underlying analysis didn't
change they just so so my question is
in the in the in the original physical
note it's talking about 2024 uh for the
political subdivisions one million
dollars and in 2025
another million dollars in 2026 another
million dollars monthly roughly but in
the revised it just has starting up
in 2026
above roughly a million dollars so where
did that other two million dollars go
it
basically that you know the the payoff
of of any unfunded piece of this and any
any uh future accruals is going to show
up in the 26-27 rate so it's you know if
if
um this was
if we if this was last year and we
hadn't done the 24 25 rates because that
would have been based on the 21
Actuarial report
um it would show up in 24 25 in the
20-year layer in which the the change
was going to be recognized would be
would go you know 24 to 43
um but so it's going to be 26 to 45
those 20 years
um so so the you know that you know it
the the money hasn't gone away it just
add two years to the end of the
20 years rather than starting in 24 and
ending 20 years from now we're going to
end 20 years from 46.
so how nervous would be the increase in
rates
to employers it's it's a it's you know
that those amounts are
fractional in the you know the you know
tenths of the basis point
um on you know you know point you know
zero X you know it may
have that here
um I didn't get the other fiscal note in
time to print one and bring it but it
you know that you know uh you know one
million uh is is a small amount the the
employers paid 620 Million last year so
you know it's less than 1 620th you know
of a percent okay increase
any other questions
thank you thank you
does the committee feel like it has a
subcommittee I feel like it has adequate
information to
discuss the bill
yes
no he's not on the subcommittee no he's
just here to to listen in and maybe say
a few things from here and there
um all right
does anybody have a strong enough
feeling to make a motion on this
particular bill
Mr chair yes um representative I know
representative goalies
no he's not Oh I thought he was no no
sorry
he's just helpful sometimes
[Laughter]
no it's uh representative Gerhard
representative Davis representative true
representative Schmidt and myself
just to clarify that
representative true to make a comment
yes
um
just uh from where I am coming from
I'm looking at an unfunded liability
to the towns
and that's always uh very difficult
Mountain for me to climb because we're
not allowed to pass unfunded liabilities
to the town
constitutionally
28-day
we can't pass unfunded liabilities to
the town I'm not sure that that yeah I'm
not sure that applies in this particular
situation representative true otherwise
the entire system would be
unconstitutional
it has to be something new
right
A continuing situation it's not the same
as something new right
you're imposing a new expenditure a new
burden on a town without paying for it
that's 28a if you're continuing
something I'm quite sure that's not the
case
so let's let's let's make sure we're
understanding correctly is there someone
officially that can uh speak to that Rd
I'm looking up but
representative Lucas can you shed some
light I'm I'm uh you're looking it up I
believe I have the constitution on my
phone usually try and do that
ten years but I mean the the point of
down of increasing expenses to
municipalities I think is perhaps the
main point that you're driving at even
more so than the unfunded or if it
wasn't an unfunded would you feel more
comfortable
I don't know if I'd feel more
comfortable if it was
if it was just then that's going to the
from the general fund but
um and I'm certainly not saying that the
whole pension system should collapse
because of unfunded liability right but
as the as the good representative
pointed out this is a new benefit
this is a new cost
it's not a new benefit it would be an
expansion of an existing benefit but I'm
I've got it here I'm not going to say
what what it means but it's brief so the
state shall not mandate or assign any
new expanded or modified programs or
responsibilities to any political
subdivision in such a way as the
necessitate additional local
expenditures by the political
subdivision unless such programs or
responsibilities are fully funded by the
state or unless such programs or
responsibilities are approved for
funding by a vote of the local
legislative body of the political
subdivision and so it says new
uh expanded or modified
Marty do you have any insight into that
yeah
I just feel like if that were the case
we couldn't do anything within Hrs
okay
thank you
well we got clarification on whether it
is or it isn't
um
representative Brian did you want to say
something yeah I representative true
brings up a very good point and if we
were to accept
you know his interpretation then
everything that was done since 1967 is
technically illegal
actually the effective date of the
amendment the Constitution was November
28 1984. it'll be after that
just to complicate it a little bit more
yeah since yeah right I'm not saying
whether or not what's right or wrong on
this I just was going to read it yeah no
I I appreciate that as well
yeah I just I mean we be it's either
doesn't apply here or we've been
breaking it left and right so for this
particular issue well some got broken
but you're right yeah well you know like
it's something definitely got broken
um
but anyway uh once again does anybody on
the committee have a strong enough
opinion on this to make a motion
thank you
yes representative Davis
I'll make a motion about to pass okay I
have a recommendation of octopus to have
a second on that recommendation
representative Gerhard recommends our
second still out to pass
would you like to speak to your motion
Representatives okay
uh representative Gerhard
well I just say it's kind of arbitrary
if you die after a certain date you only
get half it just it's just the
arbitrariness of it that doesn't make
any sense to me
so all lives are equal right so
anybody else wish to speak to it
representative Schmidt
I'm okay with the concept of the bill
the question I have is whether the the
question about 28a issue has been
resolved or not
I'd like to get clarification on that so
that we don't do something I I think
we just need to make sure we have a
legal opinion on it
so would you feel comfortable if we move
this out to pass but we find that out
before the general executive session of
the committee as a whole
I think it's a relatively simple
question to uh look into and
representative goalie has just rejoined
us just in time to resolve this
you are but perhaps you that there's a
question as to whether or not making
adjustments in HRS uh would be an
infraction on
um downshifting expenses to
municipalities so if he extends if we
expand the death benefit
um it's obviously going to create
expenses for municipalities that the
state isn't covering does that break
the Constitution
because we're going to hear much larger
recommendations in a little bit than
what we're dealing with here I would say
it doesn't we've done numerous changes
that have changed the rate of employers
and none of it that I'm aware of has
been ruled unconstitutional I mean
really every few years when they set the
new rate we're doing that if the rate
goes up or even if you change your
benefit right
okay yes representatively just just
briefly to uh representative Schmidt's
question the question is you know who
who can offer that opinion I mean uh you
know the extreme case the house could
vote to ask an opinion of the Supreme
Court but there's certainly not time for
that other than that I mean the question
is who would be accepted as an authority
to rule on it otherwise and I don't know
the answer to that
I'm seeing heads shaking in the audience
so there there there are definitely
people who think that it's not a 28 ASU
and I think it's not a 28 issue but I'm
not a lawyer and I don't blame one on
television either so I'm not going to
opine about something but I'm not sure
about
I'm I'm willing to I'm willing to sit in
the position that we can comfortably
move forward on this without breaking
28. I mean that's that's my position on
it but representative true
thank you
um I think as Representatives we're all
responsible to uh to have our own
well-thought-out opinion of what the
Constitution says and what the
Constitution means
um this is new and expanded
this is exactly what the Constitution is
talking about in my opinion
um it is a unfunded liability to the
towns
um
and with that opinion I could not
support the OTP thank you Marnie you had
something else you thought might be
helpful
to my knowledge no benefit changes
right you know it doesn't answer the
overall question because
historically there hasn't yet yeah it's
one of those strange situations where we
have a great deal to say about what
happens with the retirement system but
the expenses generally between the
employee and the employer which we're
frequently not that employer
um so I understand the confusion around
it but
like I said I think we'll move forward
with the assumption that it that it
wouldn't break a 20-day and uh and I
appreciate representative true's
comments
yes representative Gerhard thank you
chairman I just want to say I agree with
representative true I think it's a good
point being that we shouldn't need a
separate class of witch doctors to
interpret document that's supposed to
govern our activities and see if the
average person can't understand the
Constitution then we need to change it
and that's just how that makes sense to
me so anyway I agree with what he's
saying
all right I guess I would just add to
the conversation for the amount of
expense that it looks like it would
accrue and the impact to the rate that
it would have seems to be pretty
diminutive at least according to
testimony
um it's not going to place a huge burden
um on the municipalities which I am also
very conscientious of and I appreciate
that that thought
um but one of our when one of our own
dies
serving Us in that capacity
um I think they they deserve our respect
um and and being taken care of at least
at least to this level
um so I just want to add that to the
conversation and uh with that I will
actually call the roll and the movement
is ought to pass
um and I will start representative true
nay
representative Davis
yes representative Schmidt yes
representative Gerhart yes and the chair
votes yes so that's uh four four to one
that's possible pass that on to the
committee
um we'll bring up 571 next relative to
the cost of living adjustments per
certain group 2 retirees
and the New Hampshire Retirement System
this is our Cola increase spell
um
any statements from members of the
subcommittee or questions that you would
find helpful to have answered before you
can
talk about this one
intelligently
that is isn't it
um as long as there's nobody from the
community
all right representative Brian if you
want to chime in doesn't look like the
community thank you Mr chairman and uh
thank you to the committee I know I'm
not a member of the community but thank
you for showing those things uh as you
know I did 35 years on the force in
Nashua and uh watching the pension nhrs
and everything else like that and just
to brief uh because he has passed and a
lot of you may not know but there was a
gentleman a firefighter out of
Manchester that we used to call him
timer
and the gentleman uh I think he retired
God Only Knows particularly being the
firemen uh there's a lot of stuff that
happens to you uh according to the
National figures You Only Live basically
you know 10 years after you retire but
timer Beat the Clock okay and he had a
very long and healthy retirement
unfortunately the pension system at the
amount of paid at the city of Manchester
was paying that to particular time did
not keep up with his longevity okay so
uh what we have here is a system by the
state that does not have by a clock on
the regularity of putting a cola in okay
if you had a 401k per se once you retire
you make a decision on how much you
might want to pull out you know for a
particular year or something like that
members of New Hampshire retirement
system are basically on a income with
the defined benefit program so it
depletes down and you're at the whim and
the good stead of the House of
Representatives in the Senate onto
whether you're going to receive a cost
of living increase so in the situation
of uh
timer he
basically lived to the point that he was
almost Indigent you know receiving very
little money and was very sad this is a
gentleman that had well over 20 plus
years of service to his particular
community
and you know your trial ideas are
supposed to be your enjoyable ones you
know that's why you went through the you
know all the years are working and that
wasn't the case so in your consideration
of this bill I would like you to take
the story of time and to mind I'm not
pulling out your hot strings or that
wasn't my intention you did though but
but the thing is it does have an impact
because this does not come out in a
timely basis it's from time to time it
comes up to whether we're going to
support the cola and I hope it's that
you recognize it's about time
that the retirees particularly the ones
that are mapped the standards of this
have been out there for a while and they
could definitely use this to increase
their quality of life in their Twilight
Years thank you thank you representative
O'Brien I think the thing that I'm
struggling with with this particular
bill is we do have a society in which
some people are on a direct benefit or
defined benefit and some are on defined
contribution
um and when I'm when I'm thinking about
giving a cost of living increase on a
retirement program
I have to recognize right up front that
not everybody gets that benefit and I
understand uh the comment that you made
about being able to draw if you're in a
direct contribution but along with that
comes the risk of losing everything if
your Investments are are bad and there
is no mechanism by which somebody who
finds them in that situation would
equally get a cost of living adjustment
to help them and so I'm although
obviously as I spoke before I have a
good deal of respect for people in group
two of our retirement system I also want
to be careful not to give them
advantages that everybody else in
society is going to pay for while at the
same time their own retirement benefits
may be dwindling because of the market
doing poorly or whatever the situation
may be we might find ourselves in a
situation where the Market's doing
partly they're losing benefit and then
we're asking them to pay additional
money
for this for this specific group so I'm
just a little bit cautious of of that
yes yes and I think the chair is well
founded to present that opinion too uh
but I think to chair and members of the
committee need to recognize that it's uh
not all oranges we're talking about it's
apples and oranges in this type of
situation uh the people that belong to
the New Hampshire retirement system do
not pay social security
benefits so they don't uh really receive
that particular rate I know in myself
you know being retired any type of job
that I had on the outside that would
come in so I mean you're limited to a
scope you know there's the average
person so let's say they did have a 401k
or something like that does have an
entitlement to the Social Security this
does not exist for these particular
people
thank you for that yes representative
Gerhard thank you chairman I'm just
concerned that we're not addressing the
bigger issue here I mean we have a
privately owned Central Bank that's
printing money like it's going out of
style and we're trying to keep up when
we never can I just you know what I mean
it's a much bigger issue at play and I
just kind of feel like we're
sidestepping the issue and just even if
we do give a cost of living adjustment
what if it hit inflation at 20 something
percent next year and you know what I
mean they just keep on going the way
they're going which seems like the way
we're going to go do we just play this
game again next year
that's see that's my concern is we're
kind of avoiding what's really going on
and just dealing with the subsidiary
effects
anybody else uh one second
representative yes representative true
thank you Mr chair
um
do we have an FN on this I don't on my
paperwork
this might have been one of the ones
that
was coming
yes
outside
um I have a fiscal note on mine of 84
million in year 2023.
Marty is that sound correct
thank you
yes representative Brown thank you Mr
chair I know in my time being the uh
Vice chair and chair of Transportation
when we get into complex issues uh that
the chair can make a decision whether to
have uh you know somebody outside that's
more aversed into this to come up and uh
to be recognized and amongst us this
afternoon is a former member of this
committee that has had some a lot of
experience with this and that's
representative uh Steve Pearson so if
the chair would like to indulge my
request to allow representative Pearson
to maybe hit some club right we were
going to hear so much from
representative Pearson today I don't
know if I can deal with him on another
bill you know
sympathize yeah well you know there's
only so much I can do representative
Pearson welcome to the committee
our subcommittee I should say
oh
I'm not going to really
I'm not going to uh
I'm not going to render opinion either
way on this I'm just going to give you
some background here right so we're
going to
Regional competitive labor market that's
New England
there are six New England states five of
the six New England states by Statute
issue a cost of living adjustment
generally based on the CPI between one
and five percent as a minimum and a
maximum
we are the only one that doesn't do that
and that's why these bills come before
this body is because we don't have an
automatic mechanism in place to deal
with that now as you've heard during the
public hearing on this because we don't
have a mechanism to do this the state of
New Hampshire is tremendously behind
when you look at the cost of living over
the last 25 years versus what's been
granted by this body
one of the things that
was stirred around here a second ago
involves 28a I've confirmed with the
chair of this committee who has
extensive knowledge in the pension
system and I will bring up this one
point under 28a
there's a little line on there about
consent
in 1967 the cities and towns consented
to be part of the New Hampshire
retirement system that part of the
Constitution has been fulfilled
so there is not a 28-day issue in any of
this this is a system that was mutually
entered into in 1967.
so we can we can put that to bed right
now aside from that there was a
substantial State commission the
decennial commission that occurred
and that commission was never
this was never challenged
I currently sit on the decennial
commission right now but um
so
all I can all I can
request is caution
because if someone wants to go down that
road and reset the retirement system to
numbers of 1984.
I will be the first one in line to say
yes
that's fair because the because frankly
the the way the system was calculated in
84 is far better and generous than it is
today
so but again just to just to offer
perspective on the cost of living which
is the bill in front of you right now
that that is what's going on regionally
and
you know in
until the state of New Hampshire adopts
something that's that's a little bit
um automatic
you guys are going to continuously see
these bills session after session after
session after session
so I won't make you speak to this
because it would probably be an awkward
thing to answer
um
we are going to have before us just in
these four bills some really high ticket
numbers I wasn't here in 2012 when this
whole thing kind of went sideways but
now I'm sitting here trying to at least
mitigate the damage of it going sideways
10 years ago and as part of that I have
to keep into consideration
if we if we pile on too much expense all
at once that it might all go down in
flames
um so part of my hesitancy in doing it
this year even if and I understand what
you're saying but part of my hesitancy
is I feel like we got a few bigger nuts
to crack this particular year and I'd
like to get some of those nuts through
before we sure
um you know before we think about taking
this one on as and I understand
representative Brian's arguments uh I
appreciate them
um but I think in this particular
situation right now where we sit
um we have a lot of people out there who
are facing the same kind of situation
um a lot of fellow members of the State
of New Hampshire and I'm just worried
that if we pile an extra 84 million
dollars onto the other things that might
be coming out of this committee that
it'll all just get shot
so like I said I was up here to to offer
you some historical perspective on this
in it as a policy
um I just ask that you take those cons
you know those facts into account here
um
and uh I had another thought but as a
self-diagnosed member with CRS it's
taken me a second here to come up with
that so I'll I'm sure we'll be talking
again shortly we'll be talking again
shortly thank you so much
um
any further thoughts concerns from the
committee
representative true
thank you Mr chair
um and I thank the uh the representative
for giving his opinion on why it's not a
28 a issue
um
uh he was actually giving the chair's
opinion just for clarification
and
I'm sure I'll be saying the the words
28a quite a bit today that's fair
representative true
um however
I'm a little I'm very concerned with the
84 million
um
I'm almost willing to uh to let Finance
deal with that
but the policy the policy of a cola for
uh defined benefit
um
I don't think that's a good policy
I don't get a cola on my pension I don't
know many people who get a cola on their
uh outside of state of the pension I
don't know that many people who get a
pension anymore but
um the policy is what I object to on
this bill okay
did you want to make a motion on them
uh
I would move uh on uh on this Ito
I have a motion of itl from
representative true
do I have a second on that
the chair will second it
uh representative true would you like to
speak further to your motion
um
based basically what I just what I just
got through saying is I I uh I have a
problem with the policy
of uh
irregardless of if that's even the word
I think I think it is but what other
states do I'm not concerned with what
other states are doing
um I don't think it's a good policy to
have uh uh
a cola assigned to uh to the retirement
bed thank you I I actually I agree with
you on that particular issue and I once
again further say
um
just from a financial standpoint we have
I think larger nuts to crack
um
coming out of the committee subcommittee
today and uh I'd like to prioritize
those at this particular Point
personally
um
as important as this issue is so I will
call out a vote on that representative
true uh to pass representative yay
representative Davis nay
representative Schmidt
hey
representative Gerhard
um
no sorry itl it was itl and that was my
mistake
yeah I'm sorry about that
so three names in two years all right so
we'll go around on this one again but
I'm gonna put it aside for right now
I'll come back to it yep
I'm going to move on to 436 because it's
a pretty big one and and this is one I'm
actually going to start off by having
representative Pearson come forward on
well it's it's pretty simple
um it's not complicated at all
[Laughter]
right you guys just take five minutes
until he comes back
foreign
representative Pearson are you all set
I am do you have everybody back uh we do
have everybody here and uh you have the
floor
thank you I don't have a copy of 436 in
front of me right now but it's kind of
really irrelevant because this is a
rewrite a potential rewrite Amendment
so to give you a little bit of
background
um since we're since we've been talking
about the Constitution a little bit here
in
2011 the decennial commission
met as
in New Hampshire as Most states were
meeting at that time the
the alarm was sounded of State debt in
reference to pension systems and all 50
states looked at this you know their
circumstances
in the state of New Hampshire we formed
a commission to look at
what was going on and you know how do we
rein this in how do we
make changes to
not only stop the the hemorrhaging of of
formula but how do we repair it
so the decennial commission met it was a
lengthy process there was a zillion
people on it there are people in this
room that sat in on those hearings a
decade ago
and the commission issued a report
which is what commissions do
but in this particular case
The Minority Report of the commission
was weaponized
and that's the only really way to
explain it
in legislation that was filed
under the guise of the decennial
commission
was actually the minority opinion
that started a ball rolling
that forecasters folks that understand
our competitive Regional labor market
looked at and said you are about to
create a tremendous problem
and those warnings were mostly ignored
so fast forward to 2021
not only did those
warnings hold to be true they're
actually worse than what was even
forecasted
so the Constitution State New Hampshire
article 23 is very clear it says you
shall not make retroactive law
what was passed in 2011 was retroactive
law
plain and simple
so in order to
repair that unconstitutional Act
I have before you that exact thing
now imagine my surprise getting an email
from the speaker's office summoning me
to see the speaker
for those of you that have ever been
sent to the principal's office and you
know what that feels like
uh when the Speaker of the House of
Representatives does that it's a little
bit worse
the Speaker of the House said to me what
the heck is going on and I explained to
him what was going on and I was tasked
with a simple thing
how do we fix this
and can you do it
what do you say to the Speaker of the
House you say yes I can and I will so I
spent three and a half weeks some of it
involving sleep and uh came up with a
way to do this
in a phase-in approach
representative trottier filed a bill to
do it in one shot kind of a bomb out of
an airplane here
we know what that the fiscal note on
that was it's not doable we can't do
this in one shot it's not possible
the the budget of the State of New
Hampshire is just not large enough to
pull that off so
but can we do it in phases and I believe
that we can
and that's what's before you so
I'll go through this real quick a lot of
it's
shockingly simple despite all the Roman
numerals but
um
and I broke it down on the first page
section by section for you in outline
form
just so that that would be
explainable easily the one thing you're
not going to see in here
uh is the first one 21 chapter 21 of
state law involves state employees in a
medical subsidy that was or it's not a
subsidy it's a medical program that's
been in there in law for quite a long
time that involves state folks it's not
under the guise of the retirement system
but because there is a section in there
that references RSA 100a it must be
modified we can't have contradictions in
law
so that's the only reason that that
particular part
you know part 21 of the rsas is is
mentioned it's just because it has to be
you can't we would end up with a
reference to something that doesn't
exist
so if you flip to the next page the
first thing on here
and this is discussions with the chair
um
this is this is in reference to honestly
a request that came out of a Court
ruling 10 years ago
the term vested in the state of New
Hampshire has no legal definition there
are references to qualifications of a
benefit in 100a
but the term vested as we would think it
as private corporations think it doesn't
exist and
so
when the speaker
someone renewed was office I got
representative Simon was there the chair
representative McGuire was there
one of the things that we talked about
afterwards was fixing a couple of other
things that really need to be in in
Statute in the definition of vested was
one of them so the proposed definition
of vested
is that it shall mean a members
qualified for a benefit upon 10 years
we've always presumed that that's the
way the retirement system calculates
fiscal costs
it's the way we've always just kind of
Presumed to work so the fiscal note on
this is nothing
because we're already doing it
but what it does is it codifies it into
law so that there's no ambiguity as to
really what that means
the second part of this sentence the
calculation of and those two references
involve the way your pensions calculated
cannot be reduced after three years of
service that I will qualify under damage
control
right now in New England New Hampshire
has a horrible reputation
that the state cannot be trusted
to to do anything
and frankly based on past things that
we've done that's justifiably so
so what this would do is it would say
after three years of service your
calculation cannot be reduced that
provides some stability it improves our
credibility
and it just makes it where look you know
what I know what's going on you know
they're not going to make this any worse
for me
now normally you would think that'd be a
given but
considering the actions of the past
this will help repair some of that
confidence
the next part The Honorable compensation
part the reason that you're going to see
that one change and I did it in bold as
I'm trying to be consistent with how OLS
does things is that earnable
compensation right now is just a single
paragraph that encompasses both group
one and group two
so if you're going to make any sort of
an effective change
to one group you have to separate it out
that's all this does it takes that and
just separates group one and group two
so you go from
paragraphs A and B to adding C and D
verbatim language with the exception
that the group two part removes the
references out of the college teaching
system which does not they're not group
two people so there's no reason to have
it in there
the part that I struck out in group one
on the on the next page here and B
that language is redundant it's very
peculiar to see in statute the request
to do something in the next paragraph
the next paragraph tells you to do it so
it was a redundancy it's a language
cleanup thing it affects it makes no
change
and as you're as you guys are aware
especially those of you've been on the
committee for more than a term the
pension system is so complicated that
they publish their own book
you know what other RSA gets its own
book you know so this is just another
attempt to simplify things a little bit
and that again so Group C and D
it's verbatim language
with the exception of the plan and I'll
get into the plan as as we go here
it's the same thing if you flip to the
next page the definition of average
final compensation same idea we've got
to separate group one and group two out
if we're going to make an effective
change to one group or another
and that's what that does
in
the following page in paragraph to the
removal of and who have not attained
vested status prior to January 1 of 12.
if you really look at that and you
commence service in July of 11 that's
six months later
you will have to impress me tremendously
to become vested in six months I don't
care how much time you buy so it's a
little bit it's a little more gobbley
goo really in this thing you know we had
a change July 1 of 11 if that is the
Line in the Sand let's just clarify it
as the Line in the Sand
when you get to 185 you will start to
see where the transition plan comes into
effect that's why 2012 is removed and
replaced with 2013.
that's the only change in there until we
get to the the chart
and it's consistent throughout
in paragraph d
this is this is one of the biggest bones
of contention here so when
they decided to make retroactive changes
they did it
in a phased way
based on how much damage they wanted to
do to you
based on the number of years you had
already served
and they did it into two-year chunks
what's in bold here is the the taking a
chart that has two-year categories and
just expands it into one-year categories
with no change it just blows it up from
from four categories to ten
so in order to make in order to
transition people over annually
if you were to not do that you would you
would ask some people to do one thing
and ask someone else to do something
else
because of the duration of time they had
been in service so that's why the chart
expands out
sorry representative Pearson can you
just say that again sure so
I don't have a cut in in its current
form
it's eight to ten right six to eight
four to six and then less than four four
categories so by moving it out into ten
when you if the idea here is to annually
move people back into what they were
promised
in one one year at a time
I can't do that if if your category is
eight to ten I move one of you
one year and then I really move one of
you two years and that's so it to be
consistent across the board that's why
the charge yeah that makes sense yeah
does it make sense okay
now one of the things that's in here is
there are I would call them there's a
couple of concessions that are in here
because as I tell people you kind of you
have to satisfy two ladies in the room
you have to satisfy a fiscal part and
you have to satisfy a political part
one of the concerns
that comes up is the rare occasion of
someone who has an outrageous pension
I don't find outrageous pensions to be
in the public interest they're not
certainly in the interest of the health
of the pension system
and frankly those that have found ways
in the past to manipulate this system
have done damage to the rest of us
frankly
so in 2009 the the legislature put in a
pension cap system
the concession here is that to return
people back
into the the calculation and formula
that they agreed to when they took their
position
the pension cap is going to have to kind
of follow along with that so we don't
have those outrageous and they are rare
and I want to stress that how rare they
are they truly are
but in order to satisfy a public The
public's concern on this and
prevent
a future problem
especially with the Optics
the pension cap will go back to 01.
okay now
in that we have a problem
in our Cola World of not recognizing the
value of a dollar moving or the
devaluation of a dollar moving forward I
am proposing that the pension cap
annually increased by one and a quarter
percent
now keep in mind for every year you work
you get two and a half percent
so what this will not keep up with
inflation
because we all know there's no we're not
going to see one and a quarter percent
inflation for a long time but at least
it's moving the barometer here because
otherwise we get into these situations
where in 15 years we're going to have
we're going to be duking it out about
the fact that the pension cap doesn't
work anymore
and we need to adjust it and all that if
we can put a mechanism in place to
handle that now it just takes care of
itself so this isn't just dealing with a
10-year transition this is dealing with
all new hires everybody moving forward
well yes the cap would exactly it just
it just puts a restriction 1.25 or
whatever correct okay yep now
let's look at some when we look at the
devaluation of a dollar in 2009 when the
pensacap was instituted at 120 000
dollars if you translate that into
today's dollars at 38.6 percent
inflation for this region the pension
cap should be 166 thousand dollars
so this is a huge concession raising at
five grand and then starting that
process
so
it was acceptable in 2009 to put it at
120 Grand let's compare apples to apples
here and and recognize that
again from a from a policy standpoint
the general public is not going to view
166 thousand dollars as a pension that
that's going to kind of border on the
outrageous level
and that's the main gist of this now the
one other item that's included in here
and
we could potentially have retirement
the nhrs look at the look at this within
or without it at the in conversations
with the chair in the interest of
simplifying
the request was made to remove the line
the lesser of 85 percent
now imagine
it's 19. we'll go back to 1984 we we
threw that date out there when you used
to fill out your pension calculation
card it was a postcard it was what a lot
of the Republican Party think the IRS
should do for your income taxes a
postcard simple
so imagine today now you go through all
of this formulation and reductions and
twists and
hey what month did you start working so
you know depends on what you get you get
that all figured out
and then oh by the way at the end we're
going to Lop 15 off
I'm just going to take it away and it's
like whoa hold on a second here you used
to be able to call the retirement system
and say hey this is what's going on with
me what do you think I'm gonna get those
were 15 minute phone calls now it's an
appointment it's an hour easily and
they're not even going to give you a
definitive answer it's going to be
that's going to kind of be this
so you already have enough trepidation
as it is going into retirement leaving
your profession wondering knowing that
this institution does not Grant colas
generally
I've got to come up with a dollar amount
that's going to work for me
not only for the next 10 years but
probably for the next 20. I might be a
little bit high on the first 10 but I
got to roll that through
because there's no Mecca mechanism in
place for me to have a cost of living
adjustment so in a defined benefit plan
if that is the opinion that it's a
defined benefit
these folks need to have a they need to
know that this is it and they've got to
make a plan and make a decision
so when you're sitting there trying to
figure it all out
and you get your mouth done and then
we're going to lob off 15 at the end
that's just slapping you in the face
this is the only part of this document
that would apply to everyone
so again
if we can make if if you guys want to
make a request with retirement to run
numbers both ways
with the 11 Line in the Sand that's fine
but
again this was an attempt to simplify
things in a conversation with the chair
of this committee and and myself
now if you flip that page that you're
going to get into what the legalese of
what this plan does
so it takes all that language
and says okay January 1 of 2025 we're
gonna do this
now why that date
and here's where the other concession
kicks in
right now if you are say hired
a month after these changes you are
asked by the state to do a year for free
that's how the formula works out you're
going to work for you're going to work
for free
so what we're asking in order to make
this math work in order to bring the
cost down is we're going to ask for
another year but and there's a big butt
to this
the year is not free and not only is the
Year we're asking you for not free but
the year that we made you do for free is
no longer free either
so
as an example
what the the hypothetical worker that
worked that got on a month after or a
month into this right
that free year you'll get it two and a
half percent
and the Year we're asking for you'll get
it two and a half percent
now what does that do by asking someone
to work an additional year they're not
collecting
so there's a that lowers the cost of
this
because if you're collect it's almost
like a
you you put in roughly 12 percent of
your pay versus taking a hundred percent
of your pension so it's a full flip and
I Marty can probably explain that far
better than I can as to really the
mechanics of that but the longer someone
stays in the system and doesn't collect
the better it is for the system right
so this would phase in annually for 10
years
with the ask of the one year
now why did I do this
part of the reason I did it this way
was one because I asked the speaker if
it was possible and he said yes
at least from a policy standpoint
the second reason is there are folks
that are burned out
there are folks in this room that are
burned out I know they're burned out
because they've expressed that to me
this just this gives them the ability to
not have to work that year
but they're going to have to accept
their retirement based on the
calculation that is currently in statute
so they will not reap the reward of the
additional year
my concern was that if we did this in a
different manner it would force them to
work it wouldn't give them the option
and I'm not
I'm not entirely comfortable with doing
that I think that that's for some folks
they they've just been abused
because of our current labor
circumstances to the point where they
just have to go and I and I think that
that needs to be acknowledged
now
with that plan in place
a line that's uttered all the time up
here well you're imposing
something on a future legislature
we do that all the time
everything that we Bond we do that we do
a 20-year Bond we're paying for that for
20 years the people getting elected two
years from now didn't necessarily agree
to build that bridge
but when it comes to being able to to do
things in a way that's affordable
we bond this in essence is the same
Theory it takes this over a 10-year
period with concessions it it
almost rectifies
the unconstitutional act that was done
and it makes it workable now is it
possible that two years from now the
legislature the budget could say you
know what we're just not going to fund
the 25 million to do this they could
but they're going to have to deal with
the ramifications of that
because every city in town the New
Hampshire Municipal Association they're
all going to come in here and go nope
wait a minute here
you're downshifting that on to us
and with this the cost of this being
palatable and reasonable
I don't
I can't predict what will happen but it
would seem unlikely
that they would that that's going to be
the route that they go
but from a policy standpoint
the policy of this would would
all goes into effect upon Passage
because it's a plan
so that's what I'm proposing
as a way to fix this that's what I was
asked to do to fix it
and this is the best way I think I can
do that for the folks that should have
been grandfathered in
questions from the subcommittee it's a
lot of information I know and if you
don't have a basis for it it's probably
a little confusing as well
but anything for Steve
uh yes representative Lucas thank you
um so I'm looking at the fiscal note and
trying to understand it there is no
fiscal note it hasn't been run through
um I looked at it online I'm seeing a
fiscal note it's never been submitted
it's impossible Amendment what this is
an amendment it would basically replace
the whole bill oh sorry it's a rewrite
yeah it's a rewrite okay
uh yes representative Gerard thank you
chairman just a quick question how many
people are affected by the 125 000 cap
what are the numbers we're looking at
how many people get a pension that goes
up near that cap
Marty you're gonna have to help me out
with that one it's not many
um it's not you got to understand you
would have to work
holy crap you would have to do
36 years right now
so it's it's rare it's you know what I
mean it virtually no one in law
enforcement
very few
um
on occasion there would be some with
fire they have a tendency to work longer
but it's you know if if we don't adjust
the pension cap I'll tell you this in 20
years that will become what kicks you
out that's that will become what makes
you stop working in 1994 the union
leader ran a front page article because
a Manchester battalion chief
received the first 25 000 pension and
the union leader called it outrageous
why property taxes would absorb almost
half of that today
it's not livable the poverty level in
New Hampshire is forty four thousand so
as you're I know you're well aware the
dollar and the circumstances that
surround the dollar make it such that
what looks like something on the high
end today in 20 years is not
the
so people don't trust retirement system
this is an attempt to get some
credibility back they don't trust us the
retirement system they trust because
when they call them they tell them the
truth
what you said you don't get the truth oh
we get the truth from those guys as best
as they can do it you know I mean it's
it's the calculation yeah I mean when Mr
Carlin was in here talking about another
part of this
hundreds of thousands of dollars to
adjust the computer system
they used to do it on they used to do it
on a calculator on a desk and now it's
well we're gonna have to do a software
update and it's you know why
yeah you know oh yeah so it's it's the
legislature they don't trust the
retirement system does what we direct
them to do I just so all right follow up
let's follow I can't get around this
concept though is why do
I mean I don't let's say me why do we
believe that we're smarter than people
with investing their own money that
their livelihoods are going to depend on
I don't understand it we're we're saying
that the system is messed up blame it on
whoever you want we want to keep on
building into the system is there any
like is there any opportunity to kind of
create some way for people to actually
vote with the dollars and say I don't
want to participate in this and just
keep all my money no yeah not right now
the the way the law is written
um and the way that this works is that
80 of the money that is cut the checks
that are cut to people
comes from the paychecks of the current
workers
if you shut that off all right
two things happen one the legislature
becomes the one that has to pay that
because you you've shut off an income
stream and secondly we fall out of the
windfall Act
there's Federal things that now come
into place the windfall Act is what
allows cities and towns to not have to
pay social security into group two
that is why the pension system is
actually cheaper in the Republican Party
instituted it in 1967 because it's
cheaper than just paying Social Security
you don't really see that right now
because of the mess that we're in over
poor decisions in the 90s but if the
pension system was fully funded right
now
the cities and towns will be on the hook
for six percent
or or a little less than six percent
where they're looking at seven or almost
eight percent into Social Security
so that's why it happened that's why we
did it it's it's better for both groups
the the employer and the employee
all right thank you and also the
difference between a direct benefit plan
is that the employer is supposed to be
absorbing the risk and there's no risk
to the employee they get a defined
benefit no matter what they get that
money and if there's fluctuation in our
investments or whatever we we pay in the
extra
um whereas if you do a defined
contribution obviously the the employee
is going to go with the ups and downs so
it might not have as much potential
upward Mobility but it doesn't have the
same downward Mobility either
hypothetically unless we retroactively
take it away 48 states have a pension
system for their Emergency Services
folks 48 of the 50. representative
blinkus and then representation yeah I
mean the other side of it they don't
know the uh the investment in Market
risk however they do have the inflation
risk yes
thank you Mr chair I'll just add
um having served on several special
pension committees and observed uh two
decennial
study commissions uh it's been
reinforced several times that if New
Hampshire were to change over from a
defined benefit system to any other it
would cost the state much more money
that that's been verified
sure I could just ask is that because
we're not fully funded or would that be
true even if we're the system we're
fully funded
I can't tell you the mechanism
mechanations that went into that
decision but I can tell you that it was
definitely investigated by the
Legislative let's not go too far down
that road right now it's it's an
interesting conversation we'll have it
at another time
um yes representative true
thank you Mr
chess I did try to follow along uh and
just between you and I I missed by that
much
that's understandable it's it took me
three weeks to write it I wouldn't
expect you to absorb it in 10 minutes
what
you kept saying
fix it to fix to fix what okay so in in
to reiterate in 20 after the decennial
Commission in 2011
they made a substantial change to the
pension law that went retroactive a
decade in violation of article 23. so we
took away we took away promised benefits
so you imagine you you're working for
nine years there's a state trooper that
I have spoken to 21 days
21 days he would have had 10 years and
they came in and said oh you know what
we're just redoing the whole thing well
that aside the fact that it's
unconstitutional I think it's unethical
you know you you made a decision
to take into employment with the a
municipal subdivision or a or the state
based on a whole bunch of things right
you looked at pay you looked at benefits
you looked at retirement that's all part
of the package so to come in eight nine
ten years later and say oh you know what
the government can do this so we're just
gonna we're just gonna recalculate
that's why the con that's why in 1784
article 23 was put in don't do it and
they did so this
almost just undoes that what happened
for just those folks you would have had
to have been working so essentially what
it means to make the long story short is
that what you were promised when when
you signed on the dotted line to take
the job you're pretty much going to get
that not quite but a whole lot closer
than what you're going to get under our
current system by about 30 percent so um
right is that correct about thirty
percent it would depend on your length
of service yeah what the exception that
representative Simon's talking about is
there were safeguards that were put in
in 09 they call it anti-spiking
Provisions to prevent the misuse of the
system I none of those are being removed
all of the anti-spiking provisions the
150 rule I I could get into the
technical part of it but those are all
left in there so
we didn't so we were leaving the
protections for the protections are in
there for those that are but we're
giving them the opportunity to get the
retirement package that they were
promised when they signed on and not the
greatly reduced one that happened when
we retroactively so somebody somebody
signed on the dotted line said this is
what I'm going to agree to work for and
then they worked under that assumption
for maybe nine and a half years and then
after working nine and a half years
under that assumption the state came in
and said oh just kidding it's going to
be a lot less for time that they had
already dedicated themselves for
um so I mean not to put too much out
there at the moment but I agree it's not
just
um illegal it's also unethical and
immoral from my perspective but uh
representative Schmidt
thank you Mr chair uh so a few minutes
ago you used the word unconstitutional
and you said that about
two days ago no it was only about an
hour ago
um twice you use it made the assertion
that something was unconstitutional is
that ever adjudicated and declared to be
unconstitutional it the lawsuit that was
filed in 2011 was not on constitutional
grounds and I want to make that very
clear the lawsuit in 2011 sued the state
under the contract clause
I'm going to repeat this it is not a
contract it's not a contract the word
contract doesn't appear in 100a
so we lost
it was not sued under the
constitutionality of it should have been
but that's not what happened
representative Pearson Am I Wrong Am I
misremembering this did the judge say
that if it had been that they probably
would have according to folks in the
room there was an unusual
occurrence that happened where the judge
afterwards had a conversation with the
parties involved explaining why he had
to rule the way he did and offered
free legal advice to say you should have
done it this way
I wasn't in the room there are folks
that were there I've heard the story
from multiple people that were there
but so I I don't want I don't want it to
be people to think that oh well they
sued over this and they lost
that that's not what happened it's not
how that actually occurred they sued
under a false a faulty premise
but I I'm just want to make sure that
when you say the word unconstitutionally
it gets thrown around pretty freely some
conversations so if
um
it but it was never adjudicated and
declared to be unconstitutional correct
correct that would be my opinion
if we're if we're getting
you understand that
something's only unconstitutional
because things that the legislature does
are deemed and this is uh a pretty Solid
Ground I'm talking about things that are
done by the con by the legislature are
deemed to be constitutional
unless they are adjudicated and declared
by the Supreme Court to be
unconstitutional then they're
unconstitutional word gets thrown around
a lot sure so I think I I I'm
uncomfortable when you say something it
could be that what was done was improper
or illegal or unwise or whatever but if
you want me to preface when I use that
representative Schmidt I will I will do
so well I'm going to disregard the your
use of the word unconstitutional if if
it has not been adjudicated and found to
be unconstitutional by the Supreme Court
but but there were I I was here when
that lawsuit was uh you know ongoing and
the unions sued and with regard to the
colas and a number of other teachers
union suit under the coolest yep
and and the decision was uh you know
it was a pretty drastic one in terms of
declaring that this particular thing was
not
like like the colas you know they had
been done
periodically as as was appropriate but
it was uh it's it stopped and and the
state says we ain't going to do that
anymore
uh you know we've had several uh you
know one-time payments since then we've
had an occasional uh Cola and so forth
but the regular colas that had been done
quite regularly up to that point were
stopped and as you know the the previous
uh the previous actuaries that we had
had you know gotten us into the
situation we this has come up before
that
um we were told we were 125 percent
funded we we we instituted the uh the
special
um this special I'm blanking of the word
now the account that's right the special
account
um so that stopped and uh and all the
money over a certain percentage was was
uh was flowing into the special account
sure and so forth so you never had a
good year because you had bad years yeah
and revenue and investment wise you had
good years but you never had years where
it went over a certain amount because
all that money flowed into the special
account yeah that's true representative
Schmidt but it has nothing to do without
what I've got proposed in front of you
right but I'm just saying that that I
was here for all that so I do remember a
lot of it uh but but but
again I I I I want you to stick closer
to
no I I don't want to hear
unconstitutional if it hasn't been
adjudicated okay okay gotcha
would be better to say it would appear
to have constitutionality conflict
I understand that and we we hear that
word thrown around all that's
unconstitutional that no that was that
was a genuine question though is that is
that a better way to go about it I I'm
I'm fine
with a better use of legal language okay
thank you you're welcome
um one second representative Marty this
I believe is hot off the presses you
haven't had a chance to look at this at
all correct how long would it take the
uh an HRS to analyze and come up with a
physical note for it
correct this is a work group so work
session where the intent is to do so
uh after the input of the work session
right yep
yeah that would be fantastic if you
would be so kind
if you're not speaking into the mic no
yeah if there was anything of substance
it wouldn't want to
miss that out so so generally the way
um legislative analysis works I mean I
again having not seen this bill
um just from the description
representative Pierce input for it that
does seem to be some Actuarial
calculation issues with that
um uh so that would require setting the
bill out to our actuary uh under uh the
statutory framework for the way though
that works now with proposed legislation
we only send it out to the actuary for
analysis uh we know when when an LSR is
introduced
um or if a bill is amended uh by a
policy or by a committee and adopted by
that the larger body before it goes to
the next committee or the next chamber
we would run an Actuarial analysis
um on that so that's the normal course
of how that would work so so the jury
answer is saying I don't think we could
be able to take this today and ship it
off to the actuary and and run up um you
know so we're not going to head line by
the 16th yeah
so uh you know we we can if there's
anything in it that is just sort of a
mathematical exercise you know number of
head count times x you know those things
you know we can do ourselves there's no
outside costs associated with it from
the trust fund
um you know we can we can work those
through
um so you know that that's that's how we
how the process generally Works uh as
representative Pearson said uh one of
the bills put in
um last uh one of the ones that was um
recommended itl last week was sort of
the high-end possibility you know of the
range of how much anything could cost
and it's
presumably this is this is going to be
less than that but exactly what it is we
wouldn't know until we until the actuary
tells us because there's a lot of moving
parts and maybe interact with each other
in different ways
and representative Pearson you're saying
here that
the that the um source to cover this
would come out of the state budget okay
just making sure that I have that
so there's two ways to do this right you
either pre-fund it which has been a way
we've tried to do things with the with
changes since since 2011 that's kind of
been
so we haven't totally adhered to that
um the the second option is it's a rate
change it goes into the rate calculation
and the third option is a hybrid of
paying for
a chunk of it out of the budget and then
having a rate change so
um one of the things that
Finance likes is consistency and that's
why it was with the trottier bill at 249
million
this is a 10-year plan divided by 10
except in this case years 9 and 10 are
kind of already paid for by a prior
house bill because this absorbs what
that change was that was paid for last
year
so really it's years nine and ten are
already kind of paid for yeah so
um
if I can stop you there for just a
second
um
I guess one of the things that I just
need clarification on is
we're not going to be able to have an
exact fiscal note probably before our
deadline to send it to a second
committee correct so we're going to have
to make our decision solely based off of
policy and then allow fiscal to deal
with the money aspect of it and whether
or not
we're going to pay for it
does that sound right
unfortunately that's the circumstances
that we're in with the current rule
makeup
that exists from the legislature to the
retirement system the speaker has
expressed
interest in modifying that
um well you were in the room when it
happened yeah so
that the legislature needs more
flexibility
in limited cases by limited people
to get a more responsive movement out of
retirement so that we can make educated
decisions on things that
are really going somewhere okay but
thank you representative true sorry I
was oh it's been a while
thank you Mr chair
um so a question to you Mr chair and you
can direct it wherever you wish
um
and I and I realize this is just a rough
draft and all that so maybe it's a 30
increase in cost
or is a 30 increase in the retirement
benefits it's in the benefit and because
of the actual Actuarial process it's not
going to be a like straight up
and is that 30 increase in the
retirement benefits paid for by the 25
million dollars a year that's the idea
yes
in that I'm sorry no continue Matt all
that
erases
what needed to be fixed from 2011.
that's the idea yes
representative Schmidt did you want to
say something you look like you wanted
to say something oh you're pointing to
representative yes representative right
so just so I understand um
I understand this will change the
retirement benefits people who are
currently in the system get when they
retire if under some circumstance
depending on when they were hired is it
going to change the pension that people
who are currently retired will get no
and that's one of the things that is is
why we're in a bit of a sense of urgency
the first group of people affected by
this were eligible to retire yesterday
yeah so we don't have time to kick this
down the road because once you retire
that's it there's no going back there's
no recalculating there's no changes you
you're done that's that's why the seat's
so fun at the moment okay
are kind of related just to follow up to
an earlier question
um so is my understanding correct
correct me if I'm wrong that we go to
vote for I'm not on the subcommittee
when you vote for it in full committee
we don't know how much this is going to
cost and we know what the maximum amount
it would cost because in essence this is
pretty much
with without concessions the trottier
bill which we have a fiscal note for is
this concept with no concessions this
has concessions in it that would lower
the cost to the extent I don't know
because retirement has to run those
numbers Max 200. okay and is there in
the bill or are there the amendment um
does it have anything in there about
what portion would be paid out of the
general fund and what portion would be
paid
um out of the by the employers through
the retirement system in essence it does
by by flat funding that at 25 million a
year for 10 years
that is the number coming out of the
general fund whatever would be overage
if there was any would come out into the
rate but at that point you're talking a
hundreds of a percent
because you know you'd have to take you
know if it's 25.4 that year the 400 000
would and that's that's those numbers
are are almost not calculable they're so
low no follow-up yes okay so excluding
the uh value of the concessions which we
we don't know
um this would be
um 250 million dollars over 10 years and
yes to a present value is less than 250
million dollars but uh but that's
basically what you're talking about last
some unknown amount for the concessions
and also based on the fact we're in a
down stock market so in the cyclical
side of things would those numbers be
lower in the future probably yeah I mean
25 million a year we're doing cost value
averaging and effect and all that but
yeah okay you get what I'm saying with
that so thank you
in the final version of this should we
take that into consideration a little
bit as opposed to it just being a 25
million flat which is here well the 25
million flat would just stay flat and
then you know Peaks and valleys if you
will if that particular year it's a
little bit more than it needs to be then
the following year
I mean technically it has to be put in
the budget so the I guess Finance would
wiggle that number if they thought it
needed to be sure wiggled okay
any other questions
all right so
um thank you for yeah thank you so much
uh for all your work on this
representative Pearson I appreciate it
um
so it's kind of a difficult situation
it's a lot of information
um
we do have deadlines and the chair of
the committee wants us to push this
along as expeditiously as possible
um for obvious reasons as representative
Pearson mentioned that people were
already
eligible to retire who fall under this
plan
um it's a bit complicated it's a lot of
money I appreciate all of that stuff
um but we're probably going to have to
make a policy decision relatively soon
and I guess the impression that I would
just leave like to leave on the
subcommittee myself
is this is a broken promise this is
something that was due that wasn't paid
it's it's a bit different than raising
something for the future something new
for the future
um we said we were going to do this and
then we did not do this
um and it's difficult
for somebody like me who's coming along
10 years after it happened had nothing
to do with it and we have to fix it in a
very short period of time
um but I would like to at least put that
plug out there that I think that we have
a moral and ethical responsibility to
uphold our under the bargain and try to
replace
um some of the trust that the people put
in US originally
um does anybody else have from a policy
perspective on this I'm familiar with it
because I've kind of been in the process
as it's been created so I don't have as
many questions on the policy but does
anybody else have any questions policy
wise are just kind of
got feelings that you'd like to express
representative true
I don't know if I ever mentioned 28a
[Laughter]
didn't know
um
according to my notes
because all we're talking about is 436
we're not talking about this because
this doesn't exist
right so at the moment we're talking
about the amendment and not for I mean
the the what we're talking about right
now is potentially replacing 436 with
this amendment
so 436 will Disappear Completely it will
be completely replaced by this amendment
that's at least what we're talking about
at the moment before it leaves this
committee before it leaves this
committee
before the deadline
That's My Hope
yes
you may
I'm the original offer author of the
bill you're talking about and I have no
problem replacing it entirely with this
amendment I've read the whole Amendment
and I understand pretty closely how it
works and it is uh what we intended to
do in the first place so uh I would
appreciate it if you did make this an
amendment to that bill total replacement
thank you appreciate that input
uh
you and then you
so
according to my notes 436 was going to
add 133 millions in unfunded liability
I was I didn't like that idea and it was
going to add about 10 million dollars a
year
uh to the cost to the towns unfunded
liability so just so you know this one
isn't recommending that so the um the
amendment would be paid for by the state
and
with yes so with that understanding if
we can do all that in the short amount
of time we have left
then I don't think I would object to the
amendment
unless something comes out that it's not
going to be covered by 25 million a year
from the general fund uh we forgot about
a billion dollars to this to the towns
whoops my mistake
um I I just I think this
is much better than 436
. I'm uh representative my Point's just
been covered okay very good yes sir
representative Goldie
thank you Mr chair quick question
to
I know that that I know the chair was
looking to exec this next week obviously
representative Pearson doesn't have the
amendment drafted yet
um has there been any consultation with
the chair I know deadline isn't until
the following week to push this off
another week so you we can meet discuss
the full amendment in front of us and
have a little time to digest I'm not
sure that I have any other option to be
honest with you I think we may have to
do that there's just so much involved
with it
um yes I mean her preference would be
that this is exact next Wednesday for
obvious reasons we're just up against a
bunch of deadlines
um but it's such a such a big piece I'm
just not sure that we can necessarily
push it through in that amount of time
it would be nice to have one more week
to yeah it would be nice to have like
another year but
um we don't we don't have that so
um
so okay thank you representative true
anybody else have any comments on this
initially
yeah representative Gerhard thank you
chairman I think it's good I mean I
understand it's expensive but like you
said money owed
so
I mean I appreciate the work that the
representative put into work on this
this is a lot so yeah that's my position
yeah
it was fun to be there when the light
bulb went on it was uh kind of
interesting it's a good conversation
um
is it
is there anybody on the subcommittee who
is opposed to this
knows that they're opposed to this and
would like to speak to being opposed to
this
how would the subcommittee feel then uh
contradiction to what I just said about
pushing it through on a policy
perspective and then trying to hammer
out the details at the exact session
next week
kind of like building a second floor
before you got the first thing I agree
with you
all right so I'll disappoint the chair
then
the thing is I I'm very disposed to try
to do what we can to undo some of the
damage that was done you know 10 years
ago uh because promises were were made
that were not kept or promised that were
made that were broken uh and when the
court basically said you stop we're not
going to do this or this or this anymore
this is the new set of rules uh that
caused a lot of damage to not merely the
trust that the people of New Hampshire
but especially are the employees and
union members no question about it uh
and to the degree that we've got some
money available that we can start to
not only rebuild that trust but but but
to make good on broken promises I'm in
favor of that the the mechanics of the
situation are still somewhat troubling
and it seems to me like the the
represent Pearson your
then your your magnum opus here uh is is
pretty rough in terms of being able to
grasp it as whole You've got it you've
worked it all out so you understand it
for the rest of us well for for me
anyway to some degree it's kind of like
a box with a lot of parts that have not
yet been connected together right so so
to calm your fears
um OLS has gone through the references
to and they as far as which parts of the
rsas must be changed that has already
gone through OLS so this there's no
question as to that I have the right
parts modified because it's already been
done by a OLS in a different bill so
that part of it is I didn't fly blind
because to the degree that they haven't
got it done yet when we're up against
those deadlines then we're not going to
have an amendment that we can actually
vote on right either in this
subcommittee or in the full committee
you will on the full committee because
I'm going down we don't want to be there
but you're telling me that they've
they've done this work and this is
except for correcting the spelling of
the word dissemination which has two s's
or else it's a different word than I
know I have I have Word 97
representative Schmidt they they must
have changed the spelling sorry I'm
going to OLS in in 10 minutes your
statement just now is very very I know
reassurance sorry representation but I
should have mentioned that I did know
that yes representative Brian yeah thank
you I think representative Pearson just
said the whole complete thing he's going
to OLS as right after this it'll get its
uh number it'll get its stamp brought
back then it becomes part of the bill
and then you have legitimate authority
to discuss question at that particular
Point as far as my parliamentarian that
I know of that's it I mean we can
discuss all over the place but until we
got a finalized amendment that we can
vote on
that's right we're
jumping off the trapeze with no trapeze
um
yes representative Lucas uh you know I'm
not on the subcommittee but I mean if
unless I had an actual real Amendment
and some time to look at it I'd be
disinclined to vote for this in full
committee yeah no that's fair no I agree
uh just my only consideration was what I
was asked to do but I think everybody's
concerns are legitimate
um representative Gully representative
O'Brien
thank you Mr chairman
I too agree but I always worry when we
try and meet amendments with deadlines
because
most of us who've been around here long
enough know when you go to exec with an
amendment fresh off the press that there
are mistakes made and that's why I would
prefer to push it off a week because to
review the document make sure it's
correct when we have it in front of us
because we don't want to be here sitting
here waiting for a redraft as we're
executing I am going to be all over this
like I said representative Pratt and I
are going downstairs in as soon as this
work session is over that process will
start and in the Preamble like I said
was written by OLS they already wrote it
so
um we will definitely be all over that
to make sure they they don't do what you
and I both know happen sometimes and
goof stuff up and if you could please
get that to me the second you have the
second I have it that would be you want
to be a co-sponsor I would love to be a
coach okay then you'll get it the second
I get it okay yes
as soon as it's ready to go to the whole
committee because it's going to be big
and we all have to vote on it agreed
yeah no and I will make sure that it
gets to everybody for sure
me again all right well
we've got some we've got some work to do
on 436 thank you so much representative
Pearson for joining us and and bringing
this amendment forward
um we still have 449 and I was just like
a quick comments on those yes
so so what deadlines are we working with
we've got to meet the deadline for
second committee and when is that 16th
of February
right yeah so the last day that we have
to work on in committee is the 16th so
they can get to the floor by the 23rd
okay
um so subcommittee to a much emptier
room
um
we still have 449 to discuss
and that's uh representative goalie's
bill
um this brings one more element to it
that we haven't discussed in this
amendment to a certain extent which is
um giving a an increased benefit to
people who didn't fall in that 10-year
transitional period it's just for every
employee from this point forward
which is something that we need to look
at also expeditiously
um
and Steve's already left unfortunately
um I I just need a whole lot more
information
um yes yeah if you could try
I should have mentioned that too well I
did mention that to him he forgot
thanks for coming back
I thought you were going straight to OLS
you couldn't have because you're back
too quickly
I got lost
I'm glad you found your way back here
um
I'm looking at 449 we're talking about
benefits uh increased benefits to I'll
just give you the summary
or the idea anyway we're looking at
increased benefits for everybody not
just for the people who fell in the
10-year transitional window
um yeah
in that that's great within within the
context of that conversation we've been
talking about comparatively to Regional
compensation you know we're looking at
Maine Vermont Massachusetts what's
happening in those programs sure
um if we're seriously going to look at a
potential increased benefit I would like
to have those comparative numbers what
are there other places doing okay I can
give you a sum up it's I don't need it
right now um because we're gonna have to
have another subcommittee meeting anyway
you're you're I can tell you you're
going to appreciate the way New
Hampshire law is written yeah because
Maine is so bad and so it's like they
filled a bucket with mud and shot it
into the side of a barn I had to call
the state of Maine I couldn't even find
it it's so bad but
in essence we're we're not competitive
with any of the New England states at
all
so I mean I can give you some highlights
Vermont vests at two years they take
their top two years our current folks
it's top five but some of it's your
entire career average depending on what
it is
some of our stuff doesn't count at all
some of our stuff gets diluted
um depending on
how your municipality classifies it
Maine just changed their vesting in 2021
Maine went from a 10-year vest to a five
Rhode Island's a five Connecticut has
got some Municipal parts to it but
roughly a five Massachusetts state at 10
but Massachusetts in order for you to do
10 their calculations are substantially
better than ours and that's arguably our
primary competitor
from a from a labor standpoint in New
Hampshire right we literally built our
interstates for people to go to work in
Mass so
um you know if
if we want to take a deep dive in that
it's certainly welcome it to look at
what's going on around us but I'm going
to tell you guys right now you're going
to be very disappointed because we are
just we are not
as an example the city of Manchester
just lost a firefighter or let me
rephrase that a firefighter in the city
of Manchester just resigned
grew up in Manchester folks live in
Manchester he's going to the Carolinas
because what we have to offer is crap
and he has no faith in us he's gone so
this isn't you know this isn't a guy
that decided to hey I want to move to
New Hampshire because it's awesome
though I can understand that this is a
guy I grew up here
city of the Manchester police
departments lost 47 officers in the last
18 months that's a that's 25 of their
Police Department they're just done
because what we offer them today is not
competitive they go other states they
just walk away they get into other other
areas
um it's it's not just one thing it's
it's multifaceted but
we have a massive labor problem
we can't afford to lose a single person
which is the impetus of what my bill is
my amendment is is to stop people from
retiring or try to get them to stop
retiring and there's no you know in most
of these profession there's no one in
the back door Corrections has 300
vacancies the state troopers have 70
every single County Sheriff's Office is
begging for people we have
municipalities that are now stealing
employees from other municipalities none
of this stuff was happening when I
started in the emergency services 20
years ago I tested with 400 people for
nine spots
okay we have no hiring list in the city
of Manchester for the fire department
400 I feel we filled the Central High
cafeteria with applicants
so something's wrong I mean this is New
Hampshire is a great place to live we've
ex I grew up here I I have lived in
other places but
um you know this New Hampshire was a
draw there's a lot of things that we
have here that are very appealing so
when we get to the point where we can't
even attract employees or we have people
that grew up here that are leaving
it's like holy smokes okay
so yeah there needs to be a look I I'd
almost argue that there needs to be a
reconvening of the decennial commission
honestly because that's that's the
extent to which
this dive would need to happen to do it
right you could kind of piecemeal bits
and pieces I suppose as you go but if
you're going to do it properly that
commission probably should be reconvened
and really just you you would bring in
the proper people
to do analysis I guess here's part of my
question and representative Goliad
actually like some input for me
potentially on this as well um just for
starters so it seems like seems like the
priority at the moment right um because
we have weeks to deal with this and of
course we're up against the budget this
year not next year so if we missed this
this year then it's a couple years
um
I want I want to make sure that
the last piece of legislation that we
just worked on has the best possible
chance of getting getting through okay
um and part of that's Financial I'm
looking at representative goalie's Bill
uh looks like the fiscal note is 2026 13
million 320. how much of the gap between
us and our competitors
would be filled with your proposal
like how close is it going to get us to
our competitors at all close like is it
going to actually address the problem
okay so this is I mean it's not really
like information on because I think
that's why this is a commission level
request because because let's if we're
gonna any if we're gonna fix something
let's just fix it let's not throw bubble
gum on the side of the tire and keep
driving down the road here you know what
I mean well so so my question would be
going back to the conversation we had
earlier would it be wise to retain this
bill and potentially look at turning it
into a commission to actually address
the issue even though that pushes off
the potential to
address it
Mike
my concern is I I just I would prefer
sending
two options to finance with
two price tags so they have
two different vehicles to work with
um
I just am not
comfortable not knowing
finance's reaction of what's going to go
forward on a and it I've been around
long enough to see
budgeting something out over eight or
ten years
there are a lot of folks around here
that and
you can discuss it however you want
saying it doesn't happen or it does
happen that
binding a future legislation
um
legislature
to a cost
it has come up and
I'm just concerned about that and we
talk about well once we pass it
and it's paid out over 10 years that if
for some reason we decide not to fund it
well we'll have the municipalities and
we'll have everybody in here knocking on
the door so that will never happen
let me remind you the state paid 35
percent of retirement costs for
municipalities the municipalities came
in here kicking and screaming
and the legislature still cut that
funding
so that's my only concern okay
yes representative like us not on the
larger issue but um trying to understand
the fiscal note on this
I'm seeing
um you know there's a total for 2026
13.3
million and this is going to be paid by
all the employers so this one is not
funded by the state as I understand it
versus that correct and second of all is
that going to I mean that's going to be
a larger amount going forward
indefinitely if I understand correctly
is that true
that's how I read it
okay thank you
well Jeff how are we going to do this
thing about send two two plans to
finance whatever we come up with has got
to go through the house be adopted
before it can go to finance what kind of
a vehicle is going to have the kind of
options you're talking about
my concern is that if we go for the
whole Apple at once you you miss all of
it you know like if we try to address
well I I'm not going I'm only asking
right what what what's this bill going
to look like
that wants to give Finance two options
and so forth and so it would be two
different bills the one we just heard
the rip the amendment
just two separate bills okay so you're
talking about not not this bill but the
previous Bill and this bill okay
okay
because I I remember
you remember Steve because you were
sitting there I think Jeff and Diane
were there too over 301 303
double double room with about
150 guys that looked like this gentleman
here in the back with the beard okay
well I don't think you can get 450 guys
in in no double rooms they were on
multiple of course full of guys uh that
that did not look happy about where
things were or where things were going
um and so we we got to try and undo as
much of that as possible because we are
bleeding in this state we're bleeding
workers
foreign
would it be helpful to members of the
subcommittee to have representative
goalie
explain his bill again
would you mind Jeff
if you look at the bill it and um as I
pull it up the multiplier goes from the
two percent back up to two and a half
percent for the first 20 years and then
it goes to the
uh after the 20 years goes back to the
actual multiplier that's in statute now
which is and as I pull it up I'm just
recalling 2.1 percent for the first two
or three years and then it incrementally
goes up to 2.2 2.3 and 2.4 percent
if I recall correctly
so for the first 20 it increases that
multiplier to two and a half percent
for years of service
all right
well we're going to need we're going to
need one more day to work on this anyway
um
and we've been here for almost two hours
at the moment uh after a session already
so I'm gonna call the subcommittee
meeting for today oh yes representative
true
but talking about 49. this bill takes a
different approach to address the
changes of 2011. yes
doesn't the amendment that we shall not
talk of
correct all the sins of 2011. so it does
something similar but it also adds
additional benefits for people who
didn't fall it's it's not just
correcting what happened during that
time frame it's also increasing benefits
for people who are working now
this 449
so it goes It goes One Step farther than
than what the last spell we were talking
about does one fixes the past this one
fixes the past
to one extent or another and then
um addresses things moving forward as
well but does 449 correct all the sins
of 2011.
how close does it get Jeff
I'm not sure that I'm actually not sure
that it does it get as close as it
doesn't get as close as the other one
does
well yes representative Lucas plus it
seems like the other big difference is
this one has the employers paying for it
the other one is estate paying for it
although I understand the concern about
whether the state really will pay for it
in the future
all right so I'm back to where I was
um I'm going to suggest that we mold
this over for one more meeting
review these bills call me with
questions
um between now and then so that we can
be prepared to talk through it in detail
I'm going to try to rustle up a little
bit more information between now and
then so that we have that to look at and
um
we'll go from there one quick thing I
mean would it actually make sense to
pass both of these bills if they're at
least in different ways trying to solve
the same problem or is that is it one or
the other or some melding or something
um I think you could do both but they do
different things and then obviously one
you know one's going to get discarded
somewhere along the line because you
can't have both of them they'd be
conflicting that's what I was asking
whether they were both whether they were
conflicted yeah they would be
conflicting legislation so they'd have
we'd have to pick one at some point okay
and and I would assume that would be by
Finance by the time it gets there
because I don't think we can send two
conflicting bills to the Senate
yeah uh yes representative O'Brien uh
thank you Mr chairman I do have a
question of the chair uh to revert back
before I get the impression you may uh
call for a recess uh but uh I thought we
had 571 also in front of us which is the
cost of living and where a vote was
taken uh of uh you know to itl it uh
that does leave it open for further
motions is that something that the chair
wishes to uh um you know what I'll be
honest with you I'll be more than happy
to get to that today so we can go back
to 571. okay thank you Mr chair you're
welcome thank you for pointing that out
my head's in a few different places
that's why you have me I appreciate that
I knew
[Laughter]
oh okay so back to 571 cost of living
adjustments for group two
um and I apologize I realized afterwards
and this is my first time running a
subcommittee so there's a few bumps
along the road I didn't ask for further
input from the rest of the members
before I moved on either so I apologize
for that and representative Davis we can
reconsider right now if we want to on
571 that's yeah that's what we're doing
to pass
no we have to we have to reconsider
first you have to we have to vote what
it lost it lost
the the the motion the the motion wasn't
adopted yeah the motion wasn't adopted
yep
representative Davis
uh make a motion about to pass I have a
motion of all to pass to have a second
on ought to pass second I have a second
would you like to speak to your motion
representative Davis
yeah
um all of this just seems to be you know
fixing problems that have gone on before
so I'm not having any problem with that
at all okay representative Schmidt which
I thought we decided that the Ito motion
was not where we want to go so we wanted
to do something else
I am in the same position I was would
anybody else like to speak to it
all right well then I will call a vote
on it representative true
ought to pass is the motion
571 which is the cola increase nay
representative Davis yay representative
Schmidt aye
uh the chair boats and actually
representative Gerhard
nay and the chair votes nay as well so
now we're three to Nay
ought to pass fails
um
would somebody like to make another
motion on it so uh the initial itl
failed to pass has also failed
representative true
I will I'll make the motion I'll remake
the motion uh and expedient into
legislate
do I have a second
representative two seconds I've already
I've already spoken to it so I'll just
call another vote on it uh well would
anybody else like to speak to it
no representative true motion is itl on
571. yay
representative Davis nay representative
Schmidt
anyone
a vote changed so it failed
okay representative Gerhard
the motion is inexpedient to legislate
and the chair votes yes so in Expedia
and to legislate we'll go to the full
committee
um three to two
um with that I will close up the
subcommittee meeting for today and I
will most likely call or reconvene
um next Wednesday morning although maybe
next Wednesday afternoon because we
might need a little bit of an additional
time
so I will let you know
thank you for your time